それじゃだけど自分はアイリスで、イントンさんはまだシェルドンって言うか、お世話だったんだ。
お世話だったんだ。
だから、レベルはまだ前やって、トイトニー。
あ、そうじゃない。
あ、そうですか。
これとか思って。
まだ長居と。
あの、えっと、お前後さんが今、トイトニーさんが一緒なのよ。
あ、そう?
長居さんって言うんだけどね。
あ、そうなの?
そうやって、バラセータバタできだなってね。
その方、私で2年くらい若いと思う。だけど、ずっとやっぱり嬉しいんだったみたいな。
うんうんうん。
まだ福岡とか。
あ、面白いね。
うん。
そう、だから、リキちゃんたちなんて、人が、フランス語だったら少し困るかもしれないけど、
人言語とか、何かでちょっと分かる言葉で話してきても、全然困らないじゃない。
もう、自分らしいよ。ちゃんと自分はいるからだけど、
メンバーなんて、やっぱり英語で話されると、すごく、すごい困って、いつも逃げ回ってたの。
うん。
まあ、いや、ちょっと、早く言っちゃって。
なんていらっしゃらないわね。お手紙書きたいんだけど。もう。
全然聞かないもんね。そうね。
でも私もフランスであの、おつとめしてた頃に書いたのよ。お手紙。それで返事してくださって。
でもどう言ったって、もう何年?40年くらい。大事なんだ。
私は老朽生だって、もう全部。94だからね。
それも。あと、あと、スラファイルの。
どなたかのおばさまとか、まだ長見ね。
面白い。日本人なんだけど、私たちは老朽生のおばさまとか。
そういう方が何人かいたわね。
すごい。俺になりましたもんね。
もう真っ暗と。
やっぱり。